We want to know how much 1/4 is
plus 3/5 minus 3/10.
I recommend that you stop the video
and see if you can calculate it.
Okay, I guess I tried it.
Now let's make the example together.
The first you may think,
is that you have these fractions,
which you have to collect and draw,
but they have different denominators.
To get them out and collect them in the right way,
we have to record them
with the same denominator.
What we have to find is a number that is multiple
at 4, 5 and 10.
As I always say, we can use every single multiple,
but to simplify things, we use it
at least in total.
One way to find the least common multiple
is to take the largest of these numbers
and check his multiples by increasing
numbers until we find a suitable number,
which is shared by the other two.
For example, I can start with 10.
10 is divided into 5, but not divided by 4.
We continue with 20.
20 is divided into 5, and 4,
therefore the smallest total of 4, 5 and 10 is 20.
Let's write down all these fractions
like something on 20.
Let's start with 1/4.
How much on 20 is 1/4?
To get 20 out of 4, we need to multiply by 5,
then you must do the same with the numerator.
You have to multiply it by 5.
1 in 5 is 5.
1 on 4 is equal to 5/20.
4 is 4 by 1, 20 is 4 by 5.
Then we want to find out what happens with 3/5,
if I write them as something on 20.
To get 20 out of 5 in the denominator,
you have to multiply it by 4,
you must multiply by 4 and the numerator.
3 in 4 is 12.
Then we will draw 3/10,
but how do we record them as something on 20?
To get 20 out of 10,
you need to multiply the denominator by 2,
and if we want to get the same fraction,
we must multiply the numerator by 2.
3 in 2 is 6.
What will that be equal to?
Now I have 5/20
plus 12/20 minus 6/20.
What will that be equal to?
There are several ways to think about it.
You can say that this will be equal
on 5/20
plus 12/20 plus 12/20
minus 6/20, minus 6/20.
Another way to think about it is
the way I just wrote here,
5 plus 12 minus 6, all on 20.
That is how many twenties we will get as a result.
How equal is this?
This will be equal to all this,
counting the twenties is one way to think about it.
5 plus 12 is 17
minus 6 is 11.
We get 11/20.
I have 5/20, I add 12/20 and I take 6/20,
I will stay 11/20.
Let's figure out another example to practice.
I have 4/9 minus 1/6 plus 1/3.
As before, I recommend stopping the video
and try to solve the problem yourself.
What I want to do first is to write
all these fractions
with the same denominator.
To find a common denominator you must find
a total of 9, 6 and 3.
As I did before, I can
started with 9 and say "Okay,
9 is not divisible at 6.
It's 3, but it's not enough. "
I want to find a total of 9, 6 and 3
and be as small as possible.
Let's see the next number, a multiple of 9, we get 18.
A 18 is divided into 9, of course, 6 and 3.
Take 18.
Let's write everything like something on 18.
How much on 18 is 4/9?
9 in 2 is 18,
I did this with the denominator
and I must multiply the numerator by 2.
This will be equal to 8/18.
How many on 18 is 1/6?
To get 18 out of 6 in the denominator,
we must multiply by 3,
but I have to multiply the numerator by 3.
1 in 3 is 3.
And finally,
how much on 18 is 1/3?
18 is equal to 3 by 6,
1 in 6 would be 6.
You can do it otherwise, you can say
how much is 1/3 of 18? That's 6.
How old is 1/6 out of 18? This is 3.
4/9 of 18? It's a little harder,
but will be equal to 8/18.
In both ways I recorded these fractions
and put them in the appropriate color.
This is exactly the same here
like 8/18 minus 3/18 plus 6/18.
How much will be equal?
This will be some eighteen,
and if I have 8/18 minus 3/18,
this will be 5/18,
plus 6/18, which will be equal to 11/18.
And we're ready.